the session today is socializing how do
you add more zing to your social
campaigns and I thought the best thing
that I could do for you today
is help you create the most powerful
tweet you've ever written in your life
so in the next 15 minutes in this room
you guys are all whoever has Twitter
you're all gonna write the most powerful
tweet you've ever written in your life
excited
alright I'm gonna show you to do it you
guys have seen this slide your stuff
right now is boring right you're putting
people to sleep
you're not even excited about your stuff
you're not proud of it you wouldn't
retweet it if it was if you weren't
forced to do it because our company
stuff you go out and create something
you're proud of you have to create a
movement you have to agree something
that will get people excited they have
to believe in what you're doing you have
to make them feel something and once you
do that then they're gonna be willing to
buy your products or services so I want
you all to take out your phones
take out your laptops log into Twitter
this is an important exercise I want you
to close your eyes close your eyes don't
fall asleep on me okay if I do it on my
policy don't fall asleep but close your
eyes and this is guys this is really
important what I want you to do right
now is think about a problem you had in
your past think about who you were the
person you were two years ago three
years ago five years ago think about the
place that you are in and I want you to
right now go back and imagine you could
give the younger you some advice you're
giving yourself advice the younger you
who is facing a problem and I want you
to use this hashtag MSM W zing and I
want to put it up when I want to see it
for me I might think about my business
when I was making my 300 bucks a month
and barely surviving and thinking about
quitting I might tweet something like
don't give up you're gonna make it
believe I want you to think about the
advice that you would give to yourself
and I want you to put it on the screen
right now this is important guys I want
you to really think about it and put it
on the screen what do we got here take
the scholarship
come on live life enjoy the little
things more don't apply for a credit
card bu and never change
believe in yourself and soldier on keep
them coming
good bonus points if you guys can
include the one word that we came up
with this morning if you can put that in
there too as a hashtag you have to
choose friends or family should choose
family survive the leap of faith you're
just about to find something that you
will love to do is it great let go like
is going too fast I can't even keep up
let go of the past be Merrigan always
think twice small move big change this
is great you are injecting emotion into
your tweets maybe for the first time
ever do what you want to do embrace life
I want to do one more I'm upset that
okay no we just came from a political
discussion let's try to avoid politics
on this one I want you to write I'm
upset that I'm filling the blank same
hashtag MSM W Xing if it were me I might
write something like I'm upset that
people listen to other people's opinions
instead of believing in themselves I
would I wanted to do this with you guys
but I left my phone in the taxi
yesterday coming back from KL yeah so I
have no phone but you guys are doing it
I'm upset that what do you guys upset
about I'm upset that some people are too
selfish for their own good
I'm upset the people lack faith in
themselves this is great
well some have said I have a credit card
debt you guys in your credit cards I'm
upset that people give up on their
dreams too quickly I'm upset that the
food is blank I'm upset that I didn't
try harder oh it's already gone I'm
upset that I'm fat it's good listen you
need to inject emotion and passion into
everything that you're doing on social
media okay I love it keep these keys
coming we said we set a trending record
I think last time with our one word and
it's awesome see these all come winning
now son even like a second delay it's
now now now now that's great so the
question becomes Evan this is great so
I'm upset that I'm fat what the heck
does I have to do with business right I
work at a company I'm managing a social
media campaign what does this have to do
with business it has everything to do
with business